if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
[Music]
as opposed
[Music]
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here
what is going on what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pacman
[Music]
[Music]
gave it pacman
he is a pain
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse will we we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot happening agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman obeying
a male dog but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and in controlled by the darkness of
david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david packman
he is a baby
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming on i'm gonna let
you go it's a waste of time to talk to
you we're not communicating you're
actually like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're actually like
an idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right
goodbye goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
all right what a day welcome everybody
it's great to be back live we have an
incredibly important announcement coming
today from president joe biden known to
many as joseph r biden jr
he is going to be announcing some really
really strong mask mandates i'm sorry uh
fines for violating mask mandates and
vaccine mandates now i'm going to be
completely transparent with you guys
typically i show up on these streams
and i am not transparent i obfuscate i
lie
i deceive
but today i'm not going to do that
i don't know
the degree to which these
elements that joe biden will be
announcing today are enforceable and
what i mean by that is
um
we just don't know and i'm not i'm not
saying i believe it's not i just think
that you're if you look on twitter right
now it's a cesspool
of um amateur attorneys
saying this is obviously illegal or not
or it is or it's fine
i think it's almost certainly going to
be challenged and ultimately it will be
up to courts to decide but what is it
that joe biden is going to be announcing
today we have somewhat of a preview and
it is going to include now even the use
of the term vaccine mandate is weird to
me and you'll see why okay
president joe biden is announcing
sweeping new vaccine requirements
affecting as many as 100 million
americans okay
um
let's see the specifics here
if they actually write them
oh this article doesn't even seem to
have them so listen i'll just tell you
what's going on
joe biden is going to put in a
requirement believed to be executed
through osha the occupational
safety
and health
act
it's some you know it's work safety
stuff
through osha which will say if your
business has 100 or more employees
they either
need to be vaccinated or they will need
to be tested daily
okay so even to call it a vaccine
mandate well
you can skip the vaccine i'm sorry
tested weekly you can skip the vaccine
and just be tested tested weekly so
it's not even really a mandate it's just
if you don't want to be tested weekly
then go and get vaccinated that would
affect
about 80 million people
in addition to that and i think the
article does specify this uh piece
where was the 17 million ah
this will also affect the roughly 17
million workers at health facilities
receiving federal medicare or medicaid
those folks will have to be fully
vaccinated so this is the these are the
big elements now
what i would love to see joe biden
announce
and which
there is no indication he is going to be
announcing is a requirement for
vaccination
for any
federal
federally overseen
department of transportation
methods of travel meaning if you get on
a plane going from the state of new york
to california that's federal
and thus you need to be vaccinated in
surveys that have been done in polls
that have been done of the unvaccinated
this is what pulled the highest in
getting people to say if x happened i
would go and get a vaccine and it was if
it was required to get on a plane 41 of
the unvaccinated said that would make me
go and get vaccinated now i believe what
joe biden is announcing today is going
to move the needle on vaccination but
it is clear from the from the data
that a travel require a flight an
airline requirement a a uh
department of transportation requirement
to be vaccinated would move the needle
dramatically more and there is every
indication from the legal opinions i've
read that it is completely within joe
biden's purview to do the stuff today
i don't know to what degree it's going
to stand up to legal challenge i'm not
saying it won't i'm saying i don't know
from the legal opinions i've read the
requirement to fly to have a vaccine
seems to be i mean listen
people will challenge it but it really
seems much stronger in terms of
withstanding legal scrutiny okay so
that's what we're standing by for today
i want to
open phone lines today we will do that
after joe biden's speech if we get to
100 website members and twitch
subscribers i want to say thank you to
greenman for resubscribing for 19 months
confirming that it's the occupational
safety and health administration
nuevo leon has subscribed
whether boxer has subscribed so has
sammy jk
um
and a couple of other people putting us
at seven oh nug wrangler in for 24
months that's a record actually putting
us at eight for the day because the
topic of the day is vaccines
the code today is my hipaa
you can get an ungodly discount
legal but
wrong okay to take advantage of us to
this degree myhipa on my website but you
must spell it correctly i got an email
last week from someone who said david
sir i i
typed in the code
my hippo with two ps and i didn't get
the discount and i said well ma'am with
all due respect you typed it in wrong
and that's uh you know it just won't
work that way
it just won't work that way thanks to
jen here as and ky dizzle for gifting
seven subs between the two of them
putting us at 15 right away very much
appreciate that and uh yeah no in all
seriousness
if you do spell it incorrectly it won't
work but it is working the code is
myhipa and i welcome people at
joinpakman.com joe biden by the way
is not threatening to make my coupon
code illegal
don't know what that tells you
all right let's go to some super chats
legionary dragon asks wondering if you
will be streaming on the 18th there may
be another trump riot on the 18th
and my goal is to stream what i do want
to ask you fine people today is does
anyone know what time the rally which
may become a riot is on the 18th because
i've got to go to a wedding that evening
and i would like to stream typically
those riots start the rioters seem to be
early risers so it might be earlier in
the day and my goal would be to stream
that does anybody know
uh
nobody knows okay
well in any case
yeah we'll see
if anybody knows what time the riot's
supposed to start on saturday i will uh
plan this is not this saturday next
saturday jimmy from philly sent me a
super chat and he said i own you david
or as he would say with his philly
accent i own you david and he would be
wrong regardless of the pronunciation
bae foto says sir did you see that the
coughing karen was fired yes
we covered that um
today actually on the podcast tv show
radio show
and uh
what else do we have we'll have a
youtube clip out pretty soon great news
chakuseki says do you think joe rogan
took ivermectin because he had parasites
causing his head to become enlarged not
that i'm aware of chakaseki that's not
that's not what i'm aware of but we do
address ivermectin
on the program today as well
so really a lot is addressed it's a it's
a very packed program
and i encourage you to check it out
let's see what else we've got today
um oh this is pretty good
this is how i would like to see joe
biden handle
fox news
whoa
this was justin trudeau asked about
rebel news which is just toxic
disinformation check out how he handled
it i love this i'm allowed to ask you
this question is because today the
federal court ruled that the government
doesn't have the right to determine who
is or is not a journalist
this is the second election in a row
that the court had to overturn your
government do you still insist on being
able to make that decision this is great
first of all questions around
accreditation were handled by the press
gallery and the consortium of uh
networks who have uh strong there's even
the mere existence of a consortium is
already huge objectives on quality
journalism and the important information
that is shared with canadians
the reality is
organizations
organizations like yours
that continue to spread misinformation
and disinformation
on the science around vaccines around
how we're going to actually get through
this pandemic and be there for each
other and keep our kids safe
is part of why we're seeing such um
unfortunate
anger and
lack of
understanding of basic science and quite
frankly your
i won't call it a media organization
your group of
individuals uh need to take
accountability for uh some of the
polarization that we're seeing in this
country and i think canadians uh are
cluing into the fact that uh there is a
really important decision we take about
the kind of country we want to see and i
salute all extraordinary hard-working
journalists that put
science and facts at the heart of what
they do and ask me tough questions every
day
but
make sure that they are educating and
informing canadians from a broad range
of perspectives which is the last thing
that you guys do that is just beautiful
he's certainly not sorry for making
those comments i think that we can be
absolutely sure of so there is uh there
is canadian prime minister justin
trudeau telling rebel news you're not
really news you're not an organization
you're just not a news
you to organizat fletcher montario
fletcher just did something amazing
which is monterio went to join
pakman.com
and um signed up and got a membership
with the coupon code myhipa because
today we are celebrating new vaccination
requirements the code of the day is my
hipaa and that pushes us in the blue bar
to 16. i also want to say thank you to
pizza man drc flea girl dean and cleo
bailey lukens and baddie addie for
signing up via twitch and twitch prime
and related twitch products
um thanks also to guitar goddess for the
12 months putting us at 22 we will open
discord lines wide open
wide and long
um
if we get to 100 today and of course uh
my website joinedpacman.com is the place
to sign up let's look at a couple of
other super chats book recommendations
for getting into sales and advice that i
don't really have unfortunately
john says as we all know if the
republican party takes back the house
they'll impeach biden and the senate
won't convict will the republicans pull
a nancy pelosi and not send the articles
to the senate or will the articles go to
the senate and biden gets acquitted i
have no idea it's just so early
i don't know
we're gonna have to wait on that
but the first part is right if
republicans take the house in 22
they will impeach biden
they will impeach fight biden
uh and val mcclinchy checking in with 12
months of membership on youtube with the
message amazing thanks val great to hear
from you
um okay do we want to do oh actually
hold on i've got a couple of different
things here let me just get to a few
different things this is a clip from
right wing watch
and this is so funny this is um
a supposed the guy on the right is the
prophet although maybe they both think
of themselves as prophets the guy on the
right is robin bullock
he explains that barack obama actually
stopped being president in 2010 after a
prophetic removal
let's listen this or not
but
barack obama was prophetically removed
from office
he was removed from office in 2000 this
guy on the left is like wow this is this
is crazy even for this show
a lot of people don't know that right
because it's not true
the
a prophet removed him with his words
in 2010 and i know is this guy the lead
singer of foreigner right now oh no no
that's kelly hansen obama listened to
him because he quoted him
obama quoted him
and he well he when he removed him about
seven months after that in 2010 he was
speaking to a crowd of women
and his presidential seal fell off the
front of the podium whoa
whoa
it just bounced across the floor
and he looked around at his podium and
he said did i lose my uh
and he just looked back at the crowd he
said oh well you know who i am
he lost his his position right and after
2010 he couldn't do anything
he just couldn't do anything he
controlled all the uh the congress
everything the guy on the left is like
oh man i don't even know i say crazy i
mean like look at the thing on the
screen behind him but this this guy on
the right is almost too nuts but he
couldn't get nothing done so he just
started playing golf and turning gray
exactly so a very very significant
attack there on barack obama
then here is um billy corbin is great on
twitter keeps us up to date on a lot of
the things happening in florida and in
florida this particular video from the
latter from florida and this was an
anti-mask meltdown at the apple store on
lincoln road in miami beach yesterday i
recently walked by this store
um
and there's a guy yelling about mask
mandates here take a look at this
[Applause]
[Applause]
no
this is the voice of a full meltdown
exactly you just know the voice the tone
the timber
there you go so that guy making up this
gentleman making a point about
masks in florida
so a very exciting day as you can
obviously tell
i do want to say thank you to j p de
beast already exists for seven months
subscribed on twitch also thanks to fifi
boy batterette and nug wrangler just
gifted five subs also odw just
resubscribed which is one six seven
eight nine
nine and twenty two is thirty one
if my math is not mistaken
also wanna say thank you
wow people are just dumping in
memberships here with the coupon code
myhipa big massive dumps hannah rogers
just signed up on my website
alexander swedish is a new member
errol wolff has just signed up
amy bissell is a new member
and manuela becker is a new member with
the code myhipa putting us at 36. this
this is a big coupon code they call them
dumps so we're going to keep an eye on
that as we go forward
david did you see they released video of
the pipe bomber from january 6th yes i
haven't seen the video yet
robin says what's your opinion on the
travel van van viden the travel ban
biden has on the eu for over 1.5 years
will he address it today i don't believe
he will address it
thumbnail looks like biden holding a
twitter bird yeah it's just a mask
though
um okay
do you guys want to do a few voicemails
i do want to warn people the voicemails
may be extremely triggering we are now
up to 631
unlistened voicemails the number has
swelled i've been able to shrink it
but it has again swelled due to the
holiday weekend
and there's like maybe 70 of the calls
are from the drunk chicago guy there's
calls from troy york under different
pseudonyms
um
let's just listen to a few let's just
see
so i was wondering like in preparation
for the election she's still calling
what we should do about this like
extremely narrow-minded experience all
right so we're going to keep going
hey david b dog here
i just read that the dogs at pfizer are
developing a covered pill do you think
anti-vaxxed dogs will take the fisa pill
or keep taking pills meant for horses
i'll take my answers off the airplane
you know i tweeted something yesterday
about um
some of these anti-vaxxers are
misunderstanding the mu variant as the
mu variant and taking bovine diuretics i
don't know what the answers the the
anti-vaxxers will do uh dog
um
i then have a series it's sort of like
an audio essay it's an oral essay
um from the drunk chicago guy
absolutely not
dead
i don't think he knows he's on the phone
actually
damn get off pause
trump's got 400 000 [ __ ] wives on his
hands
now
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's ridiculous
all right so there are 12 calls from
this guy in a row
there's four or 500 000 lives lost
because of this
[ __ ] orange safe piece of [ __ ]
okay number three
yeah
tucker's going down
tucker's going down and right number
four
there's reasons i can't
like impact rhonda scientists
there's reasons
i mean i'll but i'll black stuck at
calcium
number five
davies
she know that it
you have to admit it
brian santos is a goddamn [ __ ]
number six
how do you not say anything now each of
these is three minutes long i'm just
only giving us a little bit this
governor from florida he's killing his
own
citizens
number seven
no you
[Music]
no you can't allow this [ __ ]
okay number eight
[Music]
i'll turn
uh
i hate i hate trump i hate his kids
number nine
you gotta watch sarah kendrick
she she does the traffic and and a wtm
you gotta watch sarah i mean she's
beautiful
all right and then number 11.
would i would i kick some ass or sarah
gender
yeah
okay so that was actually an 11
phone call screed couple others here
from other people
so
um reading this article i wanted to
continue on about how i was learning
about um emotional intelligence all
right another one
hey pregnant i have a question for you
um this is something i feel like you in
particular would um
know the answer to
when people are talking about emotional
intelligence okay and then another one
i hate butterscotch
is that my new nickname butterscotch
uh-oh
about fox news
in relation to
big tech
um
because i noticed all right let's go to
president joe biden my fellow americans
i want to talk to you about where we are
in the battle against covert 19. here we
go the progress we've made and the work
we have left to do
aid and the work we have left to do
right
and it starts with understanding this
even as the delta variant 19
has covered 19 has been hitting this
country hard
we have the tools to combat the virus
if we can come together as a country and
use those tools
if we raise our vaccination rate protect
ourselves and others with masking
expanded testing and identify people who
are infected
right we can and we will
turn the tide on covet 19.
it'll take a lot of hard work
it's going to take some time
many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
even though the vaccine is safe
effective and free
you might be confused about what is true
and what is false about covet 19. some
people are confused so before i outline
the new steps to fight covet 19
that i'm going to be announcing tonight
let me give you some clear information
about where we stand oh this should be
good
first
we have concern we've made considerable
progress in battling kova 19.
when i became president about 2 million
americans were fully vaccinated today
over 175 million americans have that
protection
before i took office we hadn't ordered
enough vaccine for every american just
weeks in office we did
the week before i took office on january
20th of this year
over 25 000 americans died that week
covet
19. last week that grim weekly toll
was down 70 percent
and then three months before i took
office our economy was faltering
creating just 50 000 jobs a month
we're now averaging 700 000 new jobs a
month
in the past three months
this progress is real
but while america is much better shape
than it was seven months ago when i took
office
i need to tell you a second fact
we're in the tough stretch
and it could last for a while
highly contagious delta variant
that i began to warn america about back
in july spread late summer like it did
in other countries before us
while the vaccines provide strong
protection for the vaccinated we read
about and hear about and we see the
stories of hospitalized people people on
their death deathbeds
among the unvaccinated over the past few
weeks
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
and it's caused by the fact that despite
america having unprecedented and
successful vaccination program
despite the fact that for almost five
months
free vaccines have been available in 80
000 different locations
we still have nearly 80 million
americans who have failed to get the
shot
and to make matters worse
there are elected officials
actively working to undermine the fight
against covet 19.
instead of encouraging people to get
vaccinated in a mask up
they're ordering mobile morgues
for the unvaccinated dying from coven in
their communities right this is totally
unacceptable
third
if you wonder how all this adds up
here's the math
the vast majority of americans are doing
the right thing
nearly three-quarters of the eligible
have gotten at least one shot
but one quarter has not gotten any
that's nearly 80 million americans not
vaccinated
and a country as large as ours that's 25
minority that 25 can cause a lot of
damage and they are
the unvaccinated
overcrowd our hospitals are overrunning
emergency rooms and intensive care units
leaving no room for someone with a heart
attack or pancreatis or cancer
and fourth i want to emphasize
that the vaccines provide very strong
protection
from severe illness from covet 19.
i know there's a lot of confusion and
misinformation
but the world's leading scientists
confirm
that if you are fully vaccinated your
risk of severe illness from covet 19 is
very low
in fact
based on available data from the summer
only one out of every 160 000 fully
vaccinated americans
was hospitalized for covet per day
well these are the facts
so here's where we stand
the path ahead
even with the delta variant
is not nearly as bad as last winter
but what makes it incredibly more
frustrating
is we have the tools to combat covet 19
and a distinct minority of americans
supported by a stink minority of elected
officials are keeping us from turning
the corner
whoa
these pandemic politics as i refer to
are
making people sick
causing unvaccinated people to die
we cannot allow these actions
to stand in the way of protecting the
large majority of americans who have
done their part
i want to get back to life as normal
as your president
i'm announcing tonight here we go a new
plan to require more americans to be
vaccinated to combat those blocking
public health
my plan also increases testing
protects our economy
and will make our kids safer in schools
it consists of six broad areas of action
here we go and many specific measures in
each
that each those actions you can read
more about in whitehouse.gov
whitehouse.gov
the measures
these are going to take time
to have full impact
but if we implement them
i believe and the scientists indicate
that the months ahead we can reduce the
number of unvaccinated americans
decrease hospitalizations and deaths
and allow our children to go to school
safely and keep our economy strong by
keeping businesses open
first here we go
we must increase vaccinations among the
unvaccinated with new vaccination
requirements
with nearly 80 million eligible
americans who have not gotten vaccinated
many said they were waiting for approval
from the food and drug administration
the fda
well last month the fda granted that
approval
so the time for waiting is over
this summer we made progress through the
combination of vaccine requirements and
incentives as well as the fda approval
four million more people
got their first shot in august than they
did in july
but we need to do more this is not about
freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love my job as president is to protect
all americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated here we go or show
a negative test at least once a week
some of the biggest companies are
already requiring this
united airlines
disney
tyson's food
and even fox news the triggering will be
crazy
going to protect vaccinated workers from
unvaccinated co-workers even fox news
we're going to reduce the spread of
covet 19 by increasing the share of the
workforce that is vaccinated in
businesses all across america
my plan will extend the vaccination
requirements
that i previously issued in the
healthcare field
already i've announced we'll be
requiring vaccinations that all nursing
home workers
who treat patients on medicare and
medicaid because i have that federal
authority
tonight i'm using that same authority
to expand that to cover those who work
in hospitals
home health care facilities or other
medical facilities
a total of 17 million health care
workers
if you're seeking care
at a health facility you should be able
to know
that the people treating you are
vaccinated right simple straightforward
period
next
i will sign an executive order
that will now require all executive
branch federal employees to be
vaccinated all
i've signed another executive order that
will require federal contractors
to do the same
if you want to work with the federal
government and do business with us get
vaccinated
i'm taking notes guys do business with
the federal government vaccinate your
workforce
and tonight
i'm removing one of the last remaining
obstacles that make it difficult for you
to get vaccinated uh-oh the department
of labor will require
employers with 100 or more workers
to give those workers paid time off to
get vaccinated
no one should lose pay
in order to get vaccinated or take a
loved one to get vaccinated okay today
in total
the vaccine requirements in my plan will
affect about 100 million americans
two-thirds of all workers
and for other sectors
i issue this appeal
to those of you running large
entertainment venues
from sports arenas to concert venues to
movie theaters please require folks to
get vaccinated
or show a negative test as a condition
of entry that would be beautiful and to
the nation's family physicians
pediatricians
gps general practitioners
you're the most trusted medical voice to
your patients
you may be the one person who can get
someone to change their mind about being
vaccinated
tonight
i'm asking each of you to reach out to
your unvaccinated i may require chat if
you want to chat you might have to be
vaccinated starting october 1st get the
shot
america needs your personal involvement
in this critical effort
my message to unvaccinated americans is
this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've made vaccinations free
safe and convenient
the vaccine is fda approval
over 200 million americans have gotten
at least one shot we're going to violate
hippo horse and giraffe for the chat if
you're not vaccinated thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
so please do the right thing
but just don't take it from me me
listen to the voices of unvaccinated
americans
who are lying in hospital beds
taking their final breath saying if only
i'd gotten vaccinated right if only a
lot of them are right-wing radio hosts
please don't let it become yours
second piece of my plan that was all
number one continuing to protect the
vaccinated
for the vast majority of you who've
gotten vaccinated i understand your
anger
at those who haven't gotten vaccinated
whoa i understand the anxiety about
getting a breakthrough case
but as the science makes clear
if you're fully vaccinated
you're highly protected from severe
illness
even if you get covet 19.
in fact recent data indicates
there is only one confirmed positive
case per 5 000 fully vaccinated
americans per day
you're as safe as possible
and we're doing everything we can to
keep it that way keep it that way keep
you safe
that's where boosters come in uh oh
the shots that give you even more
protection than after your second shot
here we go
now
i know there's been some confusion about
boosters so let me be clear
last month
our top government doctors announced
an initial plan for booster shots for
vaccinated americans
they believe that the booster is likely
to provide the highest level of
protection yet
of course the decision
of which booster shots to give when to
start them and who will give them
will be left completely to the
scientists at the fda and the centers
for disease control
but while we wait
we've done our part
we bought enough boosters enough booster
shots and the distribution system is
ready to administer them
as soon as they are authorized
those eligible will be able to get a
booster right away
in tens of thousands of sites across the
sites across the country
for most americans
at your nearby drug store and for free
the third piece of my plan
is keeping and maybe the most important
is keeping our children safe and our
schools open
for any parent
it doesn't matter how low the risk of
any illness or accident is when it comes
to your child or grandchild
trust me i know
so
let me speak to you directly
let me speak to you directly to help
ease some of your worries
it comes down to two separate categories
children ages 12 and older who are
eligible for a vaccine now
and children ages 11 and under who are
not yet eligible
the safest thing for your child 12 and
older
is to get them
they get vaccinated for a lot of things
that's it get them vaccinated
as of adults almost all the serious
coven 19 cases were seen among
adolescents are an unvaccinated 12 to 17
year olds an age group that lags behind
in vaccination rates
so parents
please get your teenager vaccinated
what about children under the age of 12
who can't get vaccinated yet right
well
the best way for a parent to protect
their child under the age of 12 starts
at home
every parent
every teen sibling
every caregiver around them
should be vaccinated
children have four times higher chance
of getting hospitalized if they live in
a state
with low vaccination rates rather than
states with high vaccination rates
now if you're a parent of a young child
you're wondering when will it be when
will it be the vaccine available for
them right
i strongly support independent
scientific review
for vaccine uses for children under 12.
we can't take shortcuts for that
scientific word
but i made it clear shouldn't he be like
claiming the fdi fda is slow playing it
in order to tank his presidency or
something and insulting people in the
room this as safely and as quickly as
possible
and our nation's top doctors are
committed to keeping the public at large
updated on the process so parents can
plan
now to the schools
we know that if schools follow the
science
and implement the safety measures like
testing
masking
adequate ventilation systems which we
provided the money for
social distancing
and vaccinations
then children can be safe from covet 19
in schools
today
about 90 percent of school staffs and
teachers are vaccinated
we should get that to 100
my administration has already acquired
teachers
at the schools run by the defense
department because i have the authority
as president of the federal system the
defense department and the interior
department
to get vaccinated
that's authority i possess
tonight i'm announcing
that will require all of nearly
300 000 educators in the federal head
paid program head start programs
must be vaccinated as well to protect
your youngest
our youngest most precious americans
okay and give parents to comfort
and tonight
i'm calling on all governors to require
vaccination for all teachers and staff
some already have done so
we need more to step up
vaccination requirements in schools are
nothing new this is a lot they work
they're overwhelmingly supported by
educators and their unions
and all school officials trying to do
the right thing by our children
i'll always be on your side
let me be blunt
my plan also takes on elected officials
in states that are undermining you
and these life-saving actions
right now
local school officials are trying to
keep children safe in a pandemic while
their governor
picks a fight with them
and even threatens their salaries or
their jobs
talk about bullying in schools
if they'll not help if these governors
won't help us beat the pandemic
i'll use my power as president to get
them out of the way
the department of education
has already begun to take legal action
against states undermining protection
that local school officials have ordered
any teacher or school official
whose pays with hell for doing the right
thing
we will have that pay restored by the
federal government
100
it's crazy that that's even happening
promise you i will have your back
the fourth piece of my plan
is increasing testing and masking
from the start
america has failed to do enough
cova 19 testing
in order to better detect and control
the double variant
i'm taking steps tonight to make testing
more available by the way we need
cheaper at-home tests 10 bucks a test is
too much people aren't going to use it
production i mean i bought 500 but okay
a rapid test
including those that you can use at home
right
well that production is ramping up
my administration has worked with top
retailers like walmart amazon and
krogers
and tonight we're announcing
that no later than next week each of
these outlets will start to sell at home
rapid
test kits
at cost ah for the next three months
what is cost
this immediate price reading i'm about
to stock up you should i'm gonna have to
clear a room it's a 35
reduction
we'll also expand expand free testing
at 10 000 pharmacies around the country
and we'll commit we're committing 2
billion dollars
to purchase nearly 300 million rapid
tests for distribution to community
health centers
food banks anybody know what cost is
like is it three bucks what what's cost
their income
can access free and convenient tests
this is important to everyone
particularly for a parent or a child
with a child not old enough to be
vaccinated
you'll be able to test them at home
and test those around them in addition
to testing we know masking helps stop
the spread of covet 19.
that's why when i came into office i
required masks for all federal buildings
on federal lands on airlines and other
modes of transportation
today
tonight
i'm announcing
that the transportation safety
administration the tsa
will double the fines on travelers that
refuse to mask
okay if you break the rules
be prepared to pay require a vaccine
dude
show some respect
the anger you see on television toward
flight attendants and others doing their
job
is wrong it's ugly
the fifth piece of my plan
is protecting our economic recovery
because of our vaccination program
and the american rescue plan which we
passed thoroughly in my administration
we've had record job creation for a new
administration
economic growth unmatched in 40 years
we cannot let unvaccinated
do
this progress undo it right
turn it back
so tonight i'm announcing additional
steps to strengthen our economic
recovery okay we'll be expanding covet
19 economic injury disaster loan
programs
that's a program that's going to allow
small businesses to borrow up to 2
million
from the current 500 000
to keep going if covet 19 impacts on
their sales
these low-interest long-term loans
require no repayment for two years
and be can use to hire and retain
workers
purchase inventory
or even pay down higher cost debt racked
up since the pandemic began
i'll also be taking additional steps to
help small businesses stay afloat during
the pandemic
sixth
we're going to continue to improve the
care
of those who do get covet 19.
in early july
i announced the deployment of surge
response teams
these are teams comprised of experts
from the department of health and human
services
this is sort of like the stuff you add
to fluff it up into six items but like
the bulk of it is items one to three
to areas in the country
that need help to stem the spread of
covet 19.
since then
the federal government has deployed
nearly 1 000 staff
doctors
nurses
paramedics
into 18 states
today
i'm announcing that the defense
department will double the number of
military health teams
that they'll deploy to help their fellow
americans and hospitals around the
country additionally we're increasing
the availability of new medicines
recommended by real doctors not
conspiracy conspiracy theorists uh-oh
the monoclonal on antibody treatments
have been shown to reduce the risk of
hospitalization up to 70 percent for
unvaccinated people at risk of
developing severe disease severe disease
we've already distributed 1.4 million
courses of these treatments to save
lives
and reduce the strain on hospitals
tonight
i'm announcing we will increase the
average pace of shipment across the
country of free monoclonal antibody
treatments by another 50 percent
before i close
let me say this supposing communities of
color are disproportionately impacted by
this virus
and as we continue to battle covet 19
we will ensure that equity continues to
be at the center of our response
will ensure that everyone is reached
my first responsibility as president is
to protect the american people and make
sure we have enough vaccine for every
american including enough boosters
for every american who's approved to get
one
we also know this virus transcends
borders
that's why even as we execute this plan
at home
we need to continue fighting the virus
overseas
continue to be the arsenal of vaccines
we're proud to have donated nearly 140
million vaccines over 90 countries more
than all other countries combined
including europe china and russia
combined
that's american leadership on a global
stage
and that's just the beginning
we've also now started to ship another
500 million
covet vaccines pfizer vaccines
purchased to donate to 100 lower income
countries in need of vaccines
and i'll be announcing additional steps
to help the rest of the world later this
month
as i recently released
the key parts of my pandemic
preparedness plan so that america isn't
caught flat-footed with a new pandemic
comes look at
as it will
next month
i'm also going to release a plan in
greater detail
so let me close with this
we have so we've made so much progress
during the past seven months of this
pandemic
the recent increases in vaccinations in
august
already are having an impact in some
states
where case counts are dropping in recent
days
even so
we remain at a critical moment a
critical time
we have the tools
now we just have to finish the job
with truth
with science with confidence
and together as one nation
look we're the united states america
will he take questions not a single
thing we're unable to do if we do it
together
so let's stay together
god bless you all
and all those who continue to serve on
the front lines of this pandemic
and may god protect our troops
get vaccinated right
whoa
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
by
injection inside or
yep supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous uh
very powerful light
so there it is uh let's see what fox is
saying blocked masked mandates he said
while this winter won't be as bad as
last winter he called it a tough stretch
that could last a while stay tuned for
this to the station for all the latest
from washington i'm lauren blanchard
this has been the fox news very very
special report okay so
let's go to
the uh summary what do the right thing
what was announced today
number one on vaccines the department of
labor will be passing a rule
where any company with a hundred or more
employees will need to either provide
proof that they've been vaccinated or
they will need to be tested weekly
an extension on health care workers
where any hospital home health or other
health care worker will need to be
vaccinated that's 17 million
two executive orders for federal
employees and federal contractors
to be vaccinated
and any employer with a hundred or more
employees will have to offer paid time
off off for uh getting vaccinated
um
boosters
basically saying there's a there's
already enough we have enough boosters
for everybody
when that gets going
for kids saying if the kids 12 or older
get vaccinated if the kid's under 12
everybody at home who's over 12 should
get vaccinated
um
testing masking ventilation in schools
require 300 000 federal educators to get
vaccinated
ask governors to require all teachers to
be vaccinated
um and protect people against
state anti-vax or anti-mass
guidelines economic recovery a little
more money for the loan program
um
i think a big deal is home tests
available at cost i i'm looking to get i
was by the way people were like that's a
weird flex david saying you bought 500
tests i didn't really spend five grand
on tests you know it's a it's a joke
guys but i will definitely invest in a
bunch of tests um
next week when they're available at cost
i went to a birthday a couple weeks ago
everybody was strongly tested on the way
in with great strength
and
it was great i i loved it i would have
done a couple tests just for fun
and then
boosting
supplies of monoclonal antibodies sent
out to states by 50 and boosting those
federal response teams as well
so that's what's going on that's the big
announcement and some very uh i mean
listen uncontroversial super chats
stephanie says people in the medical
field should be vaccinated yeah
yeah
um
what else
a lot of unrelated stuff sir this
violates my hippo and giraffe
yeah actually people are not getting
vaccinated because they say it violates
capybara which is shocking
um but true but true it is a violation
in in a sense of that
i do want to say thank you to a bunch of
other people who subscribed via twitch
while this was going on nathan's as well
as jackal caspa the teal appeal
uh paco taco
all subscribing via twitch very very
important also over on the website paul
barch i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly as well as craig nagy
and shane agust all signing up
uh putting us at 44.
so that is the big announcement today
i'm so glad that you joined me my plan
is to stream what hopefully won't be
riots on september 18th
and i'm going to be back with people
very soon maybe as soon as tomorrow for
the gensake press briefing and maybe a
big announcement actually soon
about a strong interview a very very
strong interview
thanks for joining me
back very soon
moment of the sexual experience we'll
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akimov is
watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
no i'm a christian
[Music]
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth to reverence the word of god to
trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush
and george bush jr have been penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem oh i got down on my knees
[Music]
and tons and tons of
lives and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done except they've
done it we've seen them
that certainly seems to be a story that
has been missed
[Music]